♪
>>> IN OUR SERIES "UNIFYING
AMERICA," WE ARE RECOGNIZING
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO RIGHT
INJUSTICES AND BRING COMMUNITIES
TOGETHER.
WE LIKE THE THOUGHT OF THAT.
IN THE AIRLINE INDUSTRY, LESS
THAN 6% OF ALL PILOTS AND FLIGHT
ENGINEERS IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
WOMEN.
LESS THAN 10% ARE BLACK, ASIAN,
HISPANIC ON LATINO.
FIRST ON "CBS THIS MORNING,"
UNITED AIRLINES IS THE ONLY U.S.
AIRLINES TO OWN A FLIGHT SCHOOL.
IT'S ANNOUNCING ITS NEW PLAN TO
TRAIN 5,000 PILOTS BY 2030.
AT LEAST HALF OF THEM WOULD BE
WOMEN OR PEOPLE OF COLOR.
ERROL BARNETT HAS THE STORY.
>> Reporter: TWO DECADES AGO,
NEAR RUNWAYS LIKE THESE, A TEXAS
GIRL WAS DISCOVERING HER LOVE OF
AVIATION.
>> MY GRANDMOTHER WOULD TAKE MY
SISTERS AND I TO THE AIRPORT TO
WATCH THE AIRPLANES TAKE OFF AND
LAND.
>> Reporter: A 6-YEAR-OLD
TAHCHIONA SMITH WAS HOOKED.
>> WE COULD SPELL THE JET FUEL
FOR A COUPLE DAYS AND I LOVE
THAT SMELL TODAY.
>> Reporter: YOU'VE BEEN
ADDICTED TO JET FUEL SINCE A
KID?
>> YES, SIR.
>> Reporter: THE 25-YEAR-OLD
SMITH IS ON A LIFE LONG QUEST TO
BEEN AN AIRLINE PILOT.
FLIGHT TRAINING COSTS AN AVERAGE
OF $100,000.
SO, OVER THE YEARS SMITH EARNED
SEVERAL SCHOLARSHIPS THROUGH
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS.
SHE CLEARLY REMEMBERS THE FIRST
TIME AN INSTRUCTOR HANDED OVER
THE CONTROLS.
>> ONCE I STARTED TURNING LEFT
AND RIGHT, I WAS LIKE, THIS IS
WHAT I'M GOING TO DO.
>> Reporter: SHE'S FOLLOWING THE
FLIGHT PATH OF PEOPLE LIKE
MARYANN SHEAFFER.
A UNITED AIRLINES PILOT.
>> I BELIEVE IT'S RELATED TO THE
THRILL OF TAKING OFF AND
CONTROLLING THE AIRPLANE AND
LANDING.
IT REALLY IS JUST A FEELING OF
EMPOWERMENT.
>> Reporter: BUT BOTH SMITH AND
SHAEFFER WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
IN THE FLIGHT DECK.
ONLY 7% OF PILOTS ARE WOMEN, ONE
OF THE HIGHEST IN INDUSTRY.
13% OF ITS PILOTS ARE PEOPLE ARE
COLOR.
>> THEY SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE
ACCESS OR OPPORTUNITY.
>> Reporter: IN AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH CBS NEWS, UNITED
PRESIDENT SCOTT KIRBY IS
EXCITED.
>> WE'RE EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE THE
STRUCTURE MAKEUP OF OUR PILOTS.
>> Reporter: THE ACADEMY PLANS
TO ENROLL 5,000 NEW PILOTS BY
THE DECADE'S END WITH THE
BENCHMARK HALF ARE WOMEN OR
MINORITIES.
SCHOLARSHIPS CAN APPLIED FOR
SEPARATELY.
>> YOU NEED TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES, WHAT WE'RE REALLY
DOING IS OPENING OURSELVES UP A
HUGE POOL.
UNTAPPED TALENT AND GIVE THEM
OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE THOSE
KIND OF WONDERFUL CAREERS.
>> Reporter: SMITH AND AVIATION
PROGRAM RECENTLY TOOK THE FLIGHT
DECK WITH CAPTAIN SHEAFFER.
>> I'M SO ENTHUSIASTIC WHEN I
SEE YOUNG PEOPLE COMING INTO THE
BUSINESS AND SHARING SOME OF THE
LOVE OF FLYING THAT I'VE HAD
ALONG THE WAY.
>> WHEN I SEE OTHER FEMALE
PILOTS LIKE CAPTAIN SHEAFFER IT
MAKES ME EXCITED TO KNOW AND SEE
ONE DAY I CAN BECOME A
PROFESSIONAL PILOT.
>> Reporter: AND SMITH WANTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOUNGER WOMEN SEE
HER AS AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT'S
POSSIBLE.
>> STAY DEDICATED, NO MATTER HOW
MANY NOS YOU GET, THERE'S ALWAYS
THAT ONE YES.
>> Reporter: FUELED THE AVIATION
GIRL'S DREAMS.
ERROL BARNETT.
>> I LIKE THAT TAHCHIONA SMIT